my very first movie experience was the
movie Midway with Charlton Heston and I
don't know that it was a great movie but
it was a very loud movie and I remember
the theater shaking this little theater
in a little town and I didn't really
understand that a movie was a sort of
discrete and separate experience from
life itself and so I didn't quite know
what was going on in front of me but I
knew that it was sort of a big deal and
then unfortunately a little there after
I saw jaws there with my parents which
was a mistake because we lived by the
sea and that terrified me for a long
time probably the but the real formative
movie experience for me was with Star
Wars when I was seven years old and I
remember being very excited because that
the big thing to see and I was going
with my brother and on the taxi right
there my brother told me that it was
actually just a filmed lecture about
astronomy which was really disappointing
and then we got there and the lights
went down and you know let me see the
first shot of the big spaceships and
then that door inside the rebel blockade
runner was was being blasted open and I
had no idea what was going to come
through that door and I was completely
hooked and I think a lot of people of my
generation probably kankan point to Star
Wars is one of the sort of key
movie-going moments of their lives I
mean I because i was fortunate enough to
to come from a family who worked in
movies for a long time I also became
aware of everything that had preceded
that and I worry that sometimes people
in my generation are only really aware
of Star Wars and what came after it's a
kind of a bc-ad division you know I was
lucky enough to then be kind of made
aware of film history thereafter